you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey everybody thank you
for joining us for gamespot's pull up
stage here at e3 2016 whoo yeah this
exact one yeah we've been having a blast
and there's lots of people wandering by
and looking us looking at us to make
fools of ourselves on stage all day yes
sad what's it over there at the line for
Nintendo was it along that's right lil
insane yes so they have a cap on it so
that that way once you walk down the
insane line even if you mustered up the
courage to get in line and it's just as
it's closed and then you walk away in
scientist like so many people are doing
anyway this is actually our last segment
here on the screen today but there's
still tons of great coverage coming up
on the streams to make sure you stick
around right now we're gonna play a game
that Craig actually want to vote you it
originated from from Brian so give props
to that guy go yeah oh yeah by the way
joining me I'm chapter ScrewAttack this
is craig Nick and Brian so yeah hey
everybody huh all right so the game
we're gonna be playing is called buy
rent or burn it's kind of similar to the
head childish game played back in the
day co I'm very bang or kill so
essentially what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna be giving you guys three games and
you're gonna have to decide if you will
but which one you will buy which one you
were rent which one we will burn and
that's not like piracy burn that's
actually like set it on fire good
clarity there yeah so without further
ado I hope you guys have your
whiteboards ready which has really we've
really gotten a long long stretch out of
these white boards Craig is gonna for
amazing investments up I'd like to thank
it was worth it for Norman Reedus buying
again we can't forget him he's one of
our permanent host there on the stream
let's do this alright so first up
fighting games by rental burn killer
instinct street fighter 5 and tekken 7
so which one will we buy which one would
we rinse and which ones you set on fire
all right this is gonna be tough yeah is
it yes I mean already I know right now
the debate and Nick's mind is that
killer instinct in street fighter 5 yeah
uh hmm okay so okay Nikki you're taking
this very seriously yeah I know I only
know this is happening for four hours Oh
Brian's writing is that up Craig
damn it speaking does he keep trying to
get a little extra shot there right over
that way oh yeah you're up first all
right killer instinct street fighter 5
tekken 7 which would you buy which would
you rent in which would you set on fire
you ready me ya ready Arliss i just
showed up i would buy killer instinct
because it's free it's free it's an easy
download you can you can check it out i
would rent tekken 7 because really
because tekken 7 is a game i don't know
a whole lot about i enjoy the chicken
franchise and akuma is in tekken 7 to
this little cross over there i would
burn street fighter 5 I like street
fighter I love Street Fighter see
Fighter 2 is one of my favorite games
ever street fighter 5 it's okay better
than four but I played it before I feel
like I played street fighter 5 before
right and I and I feel like I have a
better version of street fighter 5 which
street fighter third strike I'll go back
and play third strike and I'm good threw
that in there so I wouldn't hate on you
didn't hear no I know exactly I don't
know James I know exactly come with your
mind so yes I would buy killer instinct
because it's free rent tekken 7 and burn
street fighter 5 i won't you kow come
all right knee yeah you're just mad at
him for scaring the piss out of you
yesterday Resident Evil let's not talk
about that hi Nick what do you got uh
well oh my god Oh bought a killer
instinct it's exactly crate I already
own ki i already own Street Fighter 5 I
love ki so i will buy it for someone
else may give it to them so that they
can also play it hi killer and secret
someone else if i have to buy it yeah by
the rules of this game okay right making
downloader for nothing listen why would
he might have all the characters okay
GUP yeah you know i would rent tekken 7
because i'm not too well versed in
tekken this would be a chance for you to
jump in + light Craig said it's got
Akuma so coming from a street fighter
background I least have some familiarity
yeah so much hate for street fighter 5
you get this season is that right I
gotta get a minor five I actually love
this game it's not about it was the only
one left but it has died at Sophie's
Choice there are rules to buy rent burn
Chad
sacrifice sometimes Ryan are you gonna
vacuum up are you gonna be different all
right well I've done this ayah to our
said to buy killer instincts because
they're doing their ego wonderful job
with their additional characters they've
had such a great plan with the rollout
and the Kidder's they're picking I mean
we saw general Rahm up here earlier
having a blast I'm gonna say rent street
fighter 5 because they've got as a good
line of characters coming as well story
modes coming finally it's mrs. are mrs.
Blanca well yeah and cube I mean we
can't always I'm happy with your lack of
personal a they put a buca man i'm
saying burn taken seven because until i
get gone back until I have a little
orange dial hahaha I don't care where
are you going are you well you never
have a chance to have him back to set it
on fire right guys the next one is one
of the hot topics of course are
underneath 326 28 and that is virtual
reality oh no hmm batman arkham vr
resident evil 7 star wars battlefront
okay got it which would you buy which
would you rent and which would you burn
you guys are just tuning in that's the
game we're playing here on the game spot
uh co-op stream at e3 so list him again
okay it is Batman Arkham VR resident
evil 7 and star wars battlefront VI I'm
ready all right Greg y'all ready ready
to go yep cool let's see what you got
very simply I would start by buying star
wars because beings are just star wars
in general oh yeah I'd buy it yes I'd
spent 4.5 billion billion dollars to buy
Star Wars I would buy Star Wars VR
because you're in it you know I
mentioned this earlier your neck swing
you're out there going crazy or flying
in dogfights shooting the crap
everything that's awesome right I would
even like a star I don't that's the
thing I don't even like Star Wars but it
seems like an incredibly fun game that's
the crazy thing about it I would rent
Batman because i would like to pretend
to be Batman for a short amount of time
but it would not like to invest all my
time in it and we were apparel they're
talking about it the idea of being
Batman he's just like you and i that's
the thing about that man was a lot of
money in a bunch of cool equipment but
he's my martial arts man well sure but
if I was stoked
man and I could fly or I was spider-man
and I'll catch swing how can be amazing
you gotta get sick and throw up yeah the
best part about it is you get to be
Batman and then still have parents at
the end of the day yeah you just got it
all that's really uh hits get straight
to the straight to the heart there you
know what if that's the part to say you
get to meet Batman and you just like
okay what do I get to do and it's just
you as like childhood Bruce Wayne and
you're just walking down an alley and
you can't stop it you know it's coming
nope watch your parents died Batman we
are everybody hey chat James a piece of
[ __ ] everybody all right don't hate star
wars as monsta x would burn resident
evil 7 fries surprise here's the thing i
played it yesterday it was awesome I
loved everything about it the problem is
is I'm a giant weenie and I am scared of
things like this I put on the VR headset
I played it Nick recorded me I swear to
lord I had a little bit of dribbled PPE
come out of my wiener right it was so
freaking scary playing resident evil 7 I
would burn that straight to the ground
because that is a game straight from
hell I would burn the words that just
came out of his mouth look at that in
front of the e3 expo hall and let me
love you everybody this is screw attack
the lsr running it a load off any
morning everybody all right great it
took 10 years but they gave us the keys
Nick what would you do ah I would all
right I would buy back end okay I love
love love love the batman arkham games I
was very skeptical about what the Arkham
VR game would be like but I'm actually
hearing nothing but good things about it
so on that alone I'll go ahead and buy
it especially since it comes it's coming
from Rocksteady the people who made all
these great games before rent i would
say resume ville seven cuz I I love
seeing Craig well I'm not gonna use the
same wording he used but yeah the
reaction to got out of Craig is
something that drew like that showcase
for my yeah yeah it's something I'd like
to experience for myself and I think in
all likelihood a single-player story you
know like res Mabel you can get through
that in a rental I think it's very
fitting for that burn I am the star wars
fan yeah and I like star wars
battlefront I did not love star
wars battlefront and this is but but
would you maybe would love it if you
were in it yeah would you love being in
an x-wing in a dogfight going down
within the trench and all that stuff
yeah that sounds a lot like just about
every other VR game out there that
sounds amazing what is not star what
it's yeah i think the true but honest is
to have your own droid be pooping at you
will hear their dude you know what the
amazing i mentioned earlier what would
be amazing is it they remade star wars
arcade with VR like straight up how you
know that I mean that's very much what
it was cuz you got to control like it
I'm the lightsaber Oh his first person
it kind of like I'm obviously you're not
it seems like a pretty okay idea to me
I'm the him alright Brian what you got
so I'm saying five resident evil 7 you
guys are all different okay the
responses and emotions that game has
elicited so far and the two minutes
we've known about it have been fantastic
yeah just watching people's reaction all
I know how many all wood wood how many
Elwood by reza dville seven like based
on what you show of hands to the crowd
half the people are there you go alright
I'm saying red star wars cuz it's a
single mission not really a big
experience but I still 0 x star citizen
eval curry oh yeah all the space we are
stuff that's in my wheelhouse and I'm
saying burn Batman because there's
hasn't enough happened to Batman Brian
haha no I'm gonna go Baines break his
back already like there's Sonia like
cooler superhero so you can do VR with
and get a more I think a more meaningful
experience really take advantage of the
platform yeah but you have a chance to
get Rocksteady to do Batman so tonight
Rocksteady can't do other good hero
games I mean they yeah I guessing all
right well interesting you guys are all
on different already that time yes all
right this one's gonna be this is gonna
be hard even though we don't really know
that much about everything but alright
what should you buy what did you rent in
which would you burn based on what souls
the ps4 neo what they're calling it the
unannounced yet I now think the obvious
or whatever the new ps4 will be project
scorpio and or Nintendo NX so we're
going big 3 here yo man bigquery if you
buy which will microsoft sony no way
talking about but you know nothing so we
don't really just about a gauge of your
fanboy levels your fanboy flags out
right now let's find out what we got all
right one must burn one must be bought
in one you can rent for a little while
and already um let's see who I can see
this one looks hard for next this is
probably because you know nothing about
this yeah a doll on a base an opinion
off of nothing there you go just lay do
it show your fanboy brighter you ready
yeah I'm Gary you can start this time
for all right so I'm saying by the NX 0
0 because you just look at that lime in
half as elder across the way nintendo is
on the right track I believe that Zelda
they can turn things around its soda
Brian it's of course it's gonna be good
yeah any cooking for consoles yeah I
think the new systems as long as they
don't call it the wii u 2 or something
like that they're good like the wii u
again super wii u yeah all right and so
I'm saying rent ps4 the neo I already
own one I'm not out of a 4k TV I don't
have a great desire to they make that
leap now I'm saying burn Scorpio but now
saying earlier I can just go buy a new
graphics card and still get 4k stuff
teraflops right what does that even mean
I don't wanna listen I'm gonna say it
like times until it makes you feel
impressed nope i will Dinks teraflop six
is more than five dag six their block
what is it hands by Fanning quarter to
learn teraflops that's more than five
days off does something have five tariff
terrified im sue something relevant this
kind of seems more flop to your game
that's right the you know I know about
all right Greg Thomey okay sure I'm
gonna go with I'm gonna buy the Neo I'm
going to rent the NX and I'm going to
burn the Scorpio right here's my logic
the neo the PlayStation 4 they have
shown over the last two years they are
committed to making great games you know
you're going to get good games when you
play the playstation console they're
going to be exclusive to that console
and that's the door or less so good that
controllers great sale rent I know
nothing about the NX like there have
been some reddit stuff
but whatever its read it right it's it
you know it could be anything right so
there's some rumors about what it could
be but nobody knows anything about it
right I know teraflops I know I know PCs
and I know Scorpio is the thing that's
going to be the most powerful gaming
console ever I don't care how powerful a
gaming console is as long as there's
good games on it I don't care there's
gonna be able to give you till initiate
like I round of applause does anybody
agree with me on that back that guy does
all right cool I don't care how strong
is validate me that lie there mean that
guy freeze that guys and everybody else
like screw you all right Nick what do
you got hey well you saw me a racing and
riding and stuff guy was was gonna
change my mind cuz I thought Craig had a
point but then I realized no I don't
want I'm gonna buy the NX all right
surprisingly two out of three of you
guys are gonna buy the Enna's all right
why is that surprising I don't know I
just think their lines and lines around
the building reason reason being reason
being is I play a lot of pc games these
days so scorpio and neo those kind of
fall to the you know yeah whatever
there's gonna be on these games i can
probably play on PC and X though
Nintendo they always do something a
little bit weird like even if it ends up
being kind of a detriment to the console
in the long run like the Wii U at least
you know you're gonna get unique stuff
there's gonna be plenty of exclusives
and if they're made by nintendo you know
that there's a better than average
chance they're gonna be a good quality
right so that's why i want to buy the NX
i'm gonna rent scorpio cuz he's just got
a heck of a lot 6 teraflops yeah that's
a lot of flops you thought you sound
like weird allen says six teraflops
anybody that weird i love weirdo I love
read out to you did he ever say so call
about the teraflops baby hey there you
go bringing it back and burn PlayStation
video um gonna burn PlayStation neo
because as much as I love my ps4 and the
exclusive games on it all this is gonna
do that's different is 4k resolution
right no you don't know that you don't
know even told us anything this is not
the ps4 k that no this is this the Neo
that's what it's called I don't know yes
4k on our we don't they just say they
decay confirmed it's gonna happen we
don't know that's the thing about this
doesn't matter
it's gone forever on forever it's better
make in a year from now we're gonna look
back and we're gonna sneak house don't
think how stupid you were because
everyone all right I am everyone's gonna
hold you this give me crazy I'll just
burn your plan succeeds Craig this game
that we're playing here this is not a
game designer watch at James this is
what people come back to in the
histories and be like that guy was an
idiot listen the Arnett remembers Chad
all right this is gonna be four games we
want and that is the so which one do you
buy which will you rent or which will
you set on fire gone forever that is the
new zelda god of war horsey of thieves
ooh see you feed ya know yeah I know
yeah that's top o the tough one for sure
Oh God of all the god of words Ian
thieves by wrenches for birds this is a
toughy for sure I can tell how long is
the rental period good is it red ball up
to beat it you have to beat it I said it
no did he not enough to beat it like a
redbox it may be a couple days a couple
of days alright we'll go blockbuster you
have it for five days ship at the old
blockbuster resting up oh it's the work
at blockbuster yeah Johnny's no more
late fees that was fun cuz we have
customers coming in all the time and
they be like hey there's no more late
fees thinking that accounts were like
magically wiped clean and then they get
really mad when I tell them they owed us
money still Louie let's rough yep I'm
ready on first all right you ready Nick
I'm real alright so here we go I'm gonna
buy see if fees I mean you already
plated obviously in that demo we saw you
yeah yeah it didn't know there's a guy
there was a guy who everybody was joking
kind of looked like me but I wish it was
me cuz that mins i would have played
already anyway see if thieves i'm a big
fan of rare from back in the day been
sad to see what's become of them in
recent years but now they're finally
making something new something original
again and it's got me excited not only
because it's from rare but because of
the premise because it's like the way
the way they demonstrated it at the
conference is perfect cuz it's just like
a bunch of people who have no idea what
to do in the game there is no tutorial
they just kind of go
and you walk away from it with a cool
story to tell those are my favorite
kinds of games i don't like open world
or you make your own fun yeah yeah
you're a big every time you play it it's
a new adventure a new story and that's
what this game looks like it's gonna be
for me you love some crack you love some
what is it uh what's thinking me like
just cause just cause it just cause to
discuss three those are some of my
favorite open-world games ever rent i'm
gonna say zelda most zelda games once I
beat it I put it down for like years at
a time so if the rental period is enough
to beat the game I'll be good and it'll
be a great game I'm sure but once I get
it all out of my system I'm not gonna
feel strong desire to go back to it huh
all right burn god of war I love what
they showed I'm really looking forward
to the game but I've made it this far my
life having never played a god of your
game and I burned that Ivy laureus beard
they're gonna leave that candy
fatherless or also burned and dead he's
a true p told Kratos has been Birds
burned before his fatal the reason why
his body is all white is because he's
covered in the ashes of this and yeah so
you're saying is that's how you're gonna
send it i think it's nothing new to
create amelie was burnt yeah all right
Brian I owe all right so I'm saying bye
Zelda cool because you can play it over
and over again and with all the world to
explore there's plenty of new things to
do I guess that he leaves is we've had
friends confirmed this week that they
wait three people win three different
directions on the demo plateau and still
didn't see the like the entire the
entirety of the plateau and their
combined experience the rule is so big
you need more than three people do it
yes I am saying Red Sea of Thieves means
as much as I like the idea of the naval
combat I'd be worried about how many
broadsides I can take before I lose
interest and I'm saying burn god of war
because like Nick I've made it this far
in life without completing a single god
of war game I've dabbled of them I've
enjoyed the awkward sexiest should be
like wood bison click erase the only
part of god of war that you've blade is
just to watch this day see if the only
thought the button ya bastard real go I
guess
[ __ ] in my head this entire time so
clearly there's something there let's
see if that's something you'd be like so
why do you have a child and it flashes
back and great us and it's like L it's
the whole moment was like her it's like
sit her they set up the world maybe
that's just quick time events like
triangle to pull out you like what and
then it's gone and then that's why you
have a kid all right Craig all right
okay it's up to follow that I would by
pirates I'm very excited for this game I
don't know why it's just pirates I love
it all about it man I would rent Zelda
here's the problem here's the thing i
will not rent it because uh it wouldn't
be a by mainly because i feel like
they're changing so much in the game
that aren't you the one who makes fun of
people for complaining about change i'll
hold on let me finish they're changing a
lot of things like I feel like they're
changing not just the adventure aspect
of it but the way the game is played
from a from a crafting standpoint from
an adventure that having a lot of new
RPG elements into it which could which
if i was to rent i'll be able to get a
better grasp as to what exactly the game
is like if I was happen for two days I
can know if it would be like a rent with
intent to buy right rent with intent
yeah you can't just have to buy no
that's cheating it's rent it's clearly
says rinse equipment n 25 you can never
buy it don't you you can ever bite you
can only rent out your late twice okay
uh hang up his own rules you register on
the disks the integrity of the game crap
i would burn the god of war once again
god of war was one of my big winners
from e3 and I try it says a lot about
these three games right all three of
these games are going to be awesome I
cannot wait to play them and god of war
once again having spent it every time I
see a reboot of a series i say what if i
wasn't interested in it what's gonna
bring me into that what is different
about it that that wasn't in the
previous before God of War I can't wait
to play but if I had two of the three I
would burn it poor poor Kratos all three
of you guys sent him straight to Hades
it was tough man it was tough it was
yeah that was a tough one all right well
cool that was luckily I don't have any
more grueling decisions for you that was
the last one knows I feel right for the
way up you don't have to kill any more
games you've done it all oh so
I just wanted to take a second thank
gamespot so much for having us out we've
got a blast today dude this has been
awesome and of course i have to thank
nor mommy the best III ever yeah you
don't wanna read it over with his baby
hand little bit like this like I want to
thank Danny for coming on for per area
with ourselves awesomely we had a lot
dpd Xavier woods and you know Isaac
joris obviously brandon jones from easy
a and i thank you guys for coming out
and hanging out with us and thank you
guys for watching us on the ship it's
been awesome today like seriously think
and thanks dude thanks so much of these
guys for letting for letting us come out
you know oh yeah it's been fun spot that
it was awesome like giving us an
opportunity to come do this so this is
great probably they've been our best III
ever yeah you know it's been like a 7.8
go episode assessment nothing she goes
nine yeah okay so make sure you guys
don't go anywhere they're still bunch of
covers going on we're still gonna be
streaming from the floor it's just will
no longer be ScrewAttack so stay tuned
for tomorrow daily i know they got a lot
of great stuff coming up and yeah thanks
again for hosting their having us and i
will see you guys around thank you yes
but